stop the road near calico base and you
will come across rocks that used to
blend in with the scenery but vandals
ruined that and it's upsetting hikers
who used to come here to experience the
desert's beauty spray painted in
different colors of blue purple and
yellow just 15 minutes into a hiking
trail by calico basin it was reported to
save red rock a non-profit group focused
on preserving the beauty of the canyon
this hiker who does not want to be
identified because of possible backlash
by those who made the graffiti was the
person who reported seeing it on a hike
earlier this week he says the graffiti
is all over the area i live for this you
know i live to recreate the mountains
and i moved here for this to climb and
hike and
it just it hurts so this is just
somebody that doesn't have an
educational appreciation for
that doesn't see value in this place
volunteers will have to clean the
graffiti up with special chemicals which
will ultimately cause damage to the
rocks
if you do come across a vandal you are
asked to not approach them instead take
a picture if you can and report it to
the blm hotline that number is on the
bottom of your screen reporting near red
rock victoria zaha live local now